hey David we've seen John Roberts side
with the Liberals twice now once to not
end Dhaka
and this week with the Liberals on
abortion is John Roberts actually a
moderate Justice has he become more
moderate beautiful question this is
really really important we've heard in
the wake of these two decisions from the
Supreme Court where John Roberts was
against ending daca and against
requiring doctors who perform abortions
to have admitting privileges at local
hospitals and these were decisions where
John Roberts was with the Liberals so to
speak so I want to look at two things
here what do these decisions mean about
John Roberts politics but first where is
John Roberts politically ideologically
in terms of justices there is a chart
that uses a scale of plus eight meaning
ultra conservative down to minus eight
meaning ultra liberal four Supreme Court
justices this is something that's done
by Roberts and Quinn I'm sorry Martin
and Quinn on that scale John Roberts
started his Supreme Court career at a
1.5 meaning on the right but not as on
the right as Clarence Thomas for example
he was a 1.5 and John Roberts based on
his decisions has been moved down to 0.5
so he went from 1.5 to 0.5 0 would be a
perfect moderate so John Roberts
according to Martin and Quinn has
moderated since joining the Supreme
Court okay for comparison Clarence
Thomas is like between a three and a
four much more conservative Samuel Alito
has gotten more conservative he's gone
from a 1.5 to like more than a 2 so it
does appear as though John Roberts is
certainly more moderate than some of
those other justices and John Roberts
has moved a little more to the middle
since joining the court here's the real
important question though what do these
specific
decisions mean about John Roberts
ideology and it really doesn't mean much
and here's what I mean by that these
were mostly technical decisions where
John Roberts was with the Liberals so
andhaka John Roberts didn't weigh in at
all on the merits of daca or the
legality of daca in some broader way the
Trump administration brought a very bad
case against daca the case the Trump
administration made was essentially
Obama didn't have the authority to do
daca the court rejected that argument
the court said merits aside Obama did
have the authority to do this Roberts
sided with the liberal justices there on
a technical matter and in fact it should
have been 9-0 like it was such an
obvious easy decision this was just a
bad technical argument from the Trump
administration it should have been nine
nothing Roberts was with the Liberals
for technical reasons similarly this
week in the abortion case in Louisiana
what the court found in its majority
decision and John Roberts was on the
side with the Liberals and wrote the
majority opinion was that if you require
abortion doctors better said doctors who
perform abortions I try to avoid that
term abortion doctors doctors who
perform abortions if you require them to
have admitting privileges at certain
hospitals you are in a technical sense
violating roe v wade which is precedent
it's established law and for that
technical reason John Roberts was with
the Liberals it was not about the merits
of abortion the morality of abortion or
anything else so the good news is that
compared to the real ideologues Thomas
Cavanaugh Gorsuch etc John Roberts is
not so ideologically biased that he will
even get the technical decisions wrong
that's a good thing the reality is we
still need to do way better than Roberts
and we certainly need to do better than
Gorsuch and Cavanaugh and that's why one
of the important reasons for removing
Donald Trump and putting in Joe Biden
remains choices to the Supreme Court and
selections to lower courts as well we've
got a great bonus show for you today
producer Pat will be taking over the
reins I will be back with you on Monday
we are taking Friday off as a sort of
extended 4th of July holiday and then
we're back fully full power on Monday
I'll see you then